[Music]
so the board of player representatives
of the nfl players association has voted
just enough just enough got 17
approving of
the proposed labor deal so it goes to a
full vote of all union members 1900 dues
paying players if at least 50 plus one
vote in favor of the cba it will be
ratified they hope to do that vote
within the next couple of weeks russell
wilson has spoken out against the
proposed cba
said wilson on twitter on wednesday the
nba and mlb are doing it right players
come first all nfl players deserve the
same we should not rush the next 10
years for today's satisfaction i vote no
now josh
what's interesting about comments by
players like russell wilson and we'll
get to aaron rodgers but russell wilson
and jj watt aren't involved in union
leadership
when star players do a drive-by and a
kind of a vague
no without any specifics and russell
wilson really had no specifics there if
you're not involved in union leadership
the guys who are get upset because
they're the ones who have been in the
negotiating sessions they were in miami
super bowl week for their meetings there
to discuss the deal they were in la the
following week they've done the work
some of them put in 10 hours on tuesday
they get upset and if anything it
galvanizes those guys to get the word
out as to why they did what they did it
upsets them they feel like they're being
challenged and they're being
disrespected so i i in a weird sort of
way it actually helps the process of
ratification to have these star players
kind of recklessly say no because it
forces the guys who did the deal to work
harder to sell it so is it just saying
no for no sake that we need to delay
this process so it actually seems like
we're putting up a fight that we're not
just succumbing to
whatever power the owners are putting in
front and so we can't just seem feeble
and weak and take whatever deal that
they're putting on the table right now i
think the worst thing both sides did
from a pr standpoint was when this all
first came up four weeks ago that the
nflpa was getting together to talk about
this deal
both the nfl and the nflpa should have
made sure more people in the media
understood that they've spent 10 months
negotiating and they have reached an
agreement that the negotiating teams are
comfortable with now they have to sell
it to their clients and the nfl has
bought it and they're working through
the process of the nflpa buying it but
you've got too many people who are like
oh this is the first offer you never
take the first offer no this isn't the
first offer this is the product of 10
months of negotiation and there is a
mutual understanding and belief among
the negotiators that now is the time to
do the deal because you do the deal now
you do the new tv deals now the overall
pot that you're sharing is bigger
there's two deals for the nflpa to think
about what they do with the league and
what the league can then do with the
networks and if you're willing to roll
the dice on the possibility that the tv
deals will be the same next year then
you can push to try to get a bigger deal
with the union with the league rather
you're taking the risk though that
you're going to get a little bit bigger
deal with the league but the pot of
money from the tv
rights will shrink not to veer off on
this but you mentioned that these
negotiations have happened for the last
10 months what happened to the second
buy i mean the second buy seemed like it
had been mentioned for the last 10
months second advising second here's why
here's why second buy's a problem the
networks don't want the second bot
networks don't mark murphy the packers
ceo told me this last july when he was
the first one to really crystallize 17
as a possibility i've been saying for
years let's screw 18. let's play 17.
mark murphy came out at the shareholders
meeting they do every july and started
talking about 17. i got him on the phone
after that not to name drop i mean but
but it did it's true it's true it's live
not to brag it's true um he told me that
two buys they did in 1993 if you
remember you were alive in 93 weren't
you i was i was five years old well
thank you for that um i wasn't uh
but uh um
yeah no problem they did two buys that
year and the networks don't like it
because what you do is when you add in
that second buy josh you're gonna have
some weekends when you look at the slate
of games and it's like
not really good games here because
you're taking a full week and sucking it
out of the other schedule the networks
want to have that more robust weekly
schedule they don't want to have two
buys i guess i always assumed that the
17 games came with two buys though
because right now what else do the
players have to give up and i i
understand that this is going to be one
fewer pre-season game that's always been
the hook three pre-season games 17
regular season games and still one bye
and i know the focus is only on the next
10 years but what about the 10 years
after that and a lot of these players
none of these 18. that's what happens
but then
i mean the players have nothing else
once you go to 17 then it's 18 and so on
and so forth and obviously these players
aren't going to be involved most likely
in 10 years but that's my concern for
them that they've just not received
enough and obviously they've been going
on these negotiations for for so long i
i i just don't understand how it's
changing all in favor of the league
here's here's the question though what
is your leverage
and are you willing to use it yeah there
are tools available to a union under the
federal labor laws you can let the
contract expire and you can go on strike
and we've seen in the past what happens
when nfl players go on strike the league
replaces them the players eventually
cave and they show up and that's that
and we're talking see i explained this
over the weekend in a couple of
different posts i wrote about how
the nfl is so different than a normal
union
situation like a factory right a factory
shuts down for four weeks none of the
workers in that factory had a lifelong
dream of working in that factory and
the money that goes away when you miss
weeks of pro football that it doesn't
come back when you reopen a factory
after three or four weeks everybody gets
overtime they got to catch up on the
orders you actually may come out of it
with more money than you would have had
if you hadn't had a strike
that money for an nfl player is never
coming back and it's so much money look
how do you go from
a weekly check of 500 000 or 200 000 or
100 000 to nothing and that you've got
obligations your lifestyle has evolved
to to match that revenue and all of a
sudden you've got nothing it's gonna be
a lot easier for a guy who's making 25
bucks an hour to go to zero even if you
don't have savings it's easier to scrap
together what you need from friends and
family and strike fund or whatever you
need a hell of a strike fund and they've
been setting royalty money aside for the
past couple of years it's still not
going to come close to giving these guys
what they need i remember back in 2011
guys like brian mckinney went out and
got these ridiculous loans with 20 plus
percent interest
just during a lockout that didn't even
wipe out any games so that's the concern
can they stay away will they stay away
and if you're not willing to use that
piece of ultimate leverage it makes it
harder to get the best possible deal and
i guess the timing always stood out to
me too because again we've heard these
rumblings for months and months and
months but it just seemed like overnight
that it was super close that deals were
on the table but ultimately in it all
the signs point to this it's just due to
television is it not tv yeah and look
i'm
the the specifics are not yet out there
because the negotiations haven't begun
but my understanding is
we're talking about under the new tv
deals an extra 100 million dollars per
team per year that that is a reasonable
expectation that's a year from now
though so they want this to already be
in place so they can say hey we are
going to work for 10 years so let's do
these long television the deal is going
to be in place you're using labor piece
as the carrot to get these long-term
deals and
2021 is when the monday night football
deal expires all the other deals expire
2022 the new deals would kick in 2022
for monday night football 2023 for
everything else the 17 games whenever
that kicks in see that's going to be
sold separately and nobody knows how
that's going to work but those extra 16
games maybe that's a streaming option
for yahoo or amazon or youtube you know
there's all this is this is going to be
i think like a transitional tv deal
where there's still going to be huge
money from the traditional broadcast
networks but this is where they're going
to start dipping their toe in the water
in a meaningful way which means it's
gonna be maybe the whole foot in the
water with one of these streaming
companies that will give them a ton of
money and you you're gonna sacrifice
some eyeballs but you're gonna make a
lot of money that's the balance for the
nfl you don't maximize the audience but
you maximize the money when you do
business with one of these streaming
companies but we'll see how it goes they
want to have it done within the next two
weeks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports